Big Keith.
Hey, Sarah. Hey, Reza.
Hey, Keith, how are you?
There it is, good afternoon.
Good, how are you?
Good afternoon. Hey, Sarbjeet.
Good to see you. How are you doing?
Uh, you're right.
Yeah, it's Monday.
Was it a busy Friday?
It's Monday, right?
Oh, it's not true.
I hate it to, for some reason, it's a very lazy Monday for us. But yeah. Hey, Toran.
Sorry.
On.
No.
Yeah.
Hey guys, how's it going?
Good or good?
Doing well, Toran, thank you.
Hey.
Alright, is anybody else gonna join from your side?
No.
I believe Arkadi.
Our caddy should be joining us.
Yeah.
OK.
I think we should focus on the replacement that we have in this week for Ranch and coordinate all the stuff that we need. Because I should do some coordination with the MSP Corp team for his account and giving access to some boards.
Repeat.
Mhm.
So...
Yes, and that that we were applying to that on the second. I just had a call with Jessel though an hour ago, and yeah, we were talking about the same. So, once you remember, do you do you know the name of the engineer who once was being replaced with?
Mhm.
Uh, you gave me one name, Jessel, Jessel gave me another one, and I confused.
That's Karthik.
Yes, correct. So, yeah, so it was Jessel initially, but then we had a call with, sorry, it was Karthik initially, and then we had a call with Jessel an hour ago, and he suggested a different name, who is a better performer, and that's something that we agree on as well, and that's Ronan. Jessel wants to.
Kour.
to replace one with Ronan because he wants a better performing engineer with you guys. And it's not only his Ronan, Ronan, correct? And that's not only his point of view, that's our point of view as well. We also know Ronan very well. And yes, he definitely is performance-wise, numbers-wise, a better engineer.
Ronan, you said, right?
Okay.
Mm.
When it comes to uh uh Arkadi, so it's gonna be Ronan, a slight change of plan there, um, so um that the...
Can you put their name here in our chat, because I have to coordinate with them.
Sure, so it's I'll just put once with Ronan here.
But the, what's the reason of this replacement for Jessel?
Sorry, again, what was the question?
What's the, what's the reason behind up that? Why just I wanna, yeah?
Behind the name change.
Yeah, he recently, he says he recently noticed some issues with Karthikey and he would not like to.
Mm.
Here is the start.
Sorry, yeah, I am. I'm audible now, right? OK, cool.
Now, if you closed for, yes, you're back.
Okay, so he he was he's being very kind and saying that he though got there's slight improvement and we're working on how Arkadi K does, but he doesn't want to share a person who has slight challenges with you guys. So he'd like to work on it himself and sharing a better resource with you guys. Yeah.
I see.
Yeah.
It.
OK, OK, that's cool. Uh, yeah, what's their name? What's their last name? Ronan? What 'cause you know I should send email?
I'll put it, I'll put it here, I'll put it here.
That's the last name, Ronald Bunde.
I see, OK.
Yeah, find it.
Oh yeah, I'm going to go and send email to, I'm not sure if we have that email in our thread. Let's see what we have. The last email that I see in our thread was from Karine and I already spoke with her.
Mhm.
See, ITBD.
Mm.
Replacements.
Because joining us in your program, OK, and Scott.
Do you have any email from Jessel for this replacement or?
No, it was, you mean the name change, the name swap? No, it was just a message that came in earlier today and I immediately set up a call just to talk with him about it.
Yeah, yeah.
Hi.
I see. OK, OK, so I'm gonna, I'm gonna send.
Kip.
Do you want me to drop an email to you both talking about this conversation? I'll do that.
Yeah, I think it's the best way. Just drop an email to us. I'm going to reply back to them and say, okay, as per this discussion, we're going to replace Ronan, and then I have to open a ticket with MSP Corp to give them access to some stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
Cool.
Right, I'll drop an email right after this call. That's one. Second is the handover bit. I mean, I think Jessel was comfortable with July 2nd. You guys comfortable with July 2nd as well? And if so, then what time works for you?
Kip.
Typically, we can make it at 10:30 EST time, 'cause you know we need we need enough time to set up something and it would be a same orientation meeting that we we already have with the new hire. We need to set up their device, we need to join them to to our MSP account.
Mm.
MBC MBC account and test his access to trace CX and all the stuff that we need and then start training.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Okay, all right, I understand. 1030 Eastern, I'll check with what time was suggested by Jessel as well so that there's no conflict. I'll look into that piece and if there's anything required to connect with you guys on Teams for sure. All righty, I think that's it.
Yep.
That, and here, Arkadi.
No, no.
You're muted.
I will quickly share my screen with you guys.
But.
Okay, let me debrief what happened so far to Arkadi.
Sure.
We OK, we agreed to do the replacement on July 2nd for Ranch. We then the guy.
Name the is Ronan.
Ronan.
Yeah, and then what we need to do today and tomorrow is we should open a ticket with MSP Core, mention about this replacement, ask them to give Ronan access to our service board. Also, how...
we need to have some information about their phone number and those staff to create an account in NBC side and prepare everything for him for July 2nd. And then July 2nd at 1030, we're going to have an orientation meeting with Ronan.
Kip.
And.
Set up their device, make sure that he has access to everything that he needs, and then on that time we can disable Vanch account. I'm not sure Vanch part gonna handle with Jessel with MSP Corp.
Because, you know, there are a couple of boards that I think manage needs to have access to, so it can handle by Jessel on their side.
Yep, yep.
Any other things you need, you think we need to do, Arkadi?
Kason.
Yeah, if possible, can we install the central agent on that machine and register the machine beforehand?
Yeah.
on the device that he'll be using.
Ohh yeah, yeah, it's a good, good, good idea if we can install it in Central Limit Agent on their machine, and then we can connect to that machine, configure it, prepare it for about the start date.
Yeah.
Yep.
Okay, okay.
So we don't have to waste so much time like we did the last few orientation sessions, waiting for the internal IT department to install this, install that, you know, add this or that. We can do all this in advance.
Hmm.
So, and Central and Central won't be on his machine already.
Shouldn't be, because you know, and centralize the software that we only use in our BU.
Thank you.
Ohh, okay, okay, alright, so I'll connect with Jessel on that, please, then.
Yep.
You can replicate what's already there on Jimmy's machine on Paxon's machine, and then, but Jasper's machine, and so on right.
Mm-hmm.
Makes sense.
And does he work for him same same location that venture Jasper thing?
Does they work in the same? Does he work in the same location, or is there a different?
Is it in Noida or Delhi or somewhere else?
In the night, yes.
He's in Nida, Ronan is in Nida, and me, Keith, we all are in the same location.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Also, let's make sure that he's able to access the office Wi-Fi with his phone, because if he's on cellular, you can't register his phone, because that's a different IP.
Yeah.
Okay.
It.
Probably, Keith, you, me, and Ashish can work on this one.
I think that.
Yeah, exactly. I think the best way is having a call between you Sarbjeet and Arkadi and that guy and IT internal to address those today if we have time, if you have time.
Sure.
Okay.
So.
For sure.
OK, OK.
Sounds good.
Right.
That works. Thank you, Arkadi.
Alright, hope my screen is visible to you guys.
The deck is prepared a little differently from how it's usually showcased. So consider this to be like a trial, if we can call that. If you see that something needs to be changed or something needs to go back to how it was, or any modifications required, you can just let me know. So the agenda would be...
Yep.
Typically the same, the check-in highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of your customer, way forward, and recap. We'll start with the check-in first. Anything you'd like to share when it comes to the performance of the engineers that we have in this board? Anything you'd like to bring up?
I.
What do you have in your site?
Sorry.
What items you have as a KPO performance stuff here or you want to...
Uh, you want you? I mean, yeah, I'll go through the numbers in a bit, but otherwise, have you have you noticed any any any complaints you'd like to highlight anything you've?
Yeah.
Mhm.
We are, we were speaking about Jas and uh, who else? Paxton and Jimmy, right?
Yes.
So, 'cause we we wanna we wanna put the branch name aside, 'cause you know it's wasting the time if we wanna talk about what happened. OK, Arkadi, Torin, do you have anything to mention about those?
Mm.
The.
Okay.
No complaints. Jasper is doing well. Jimmy and Baston are progressing in their training quite well. Jimmy is starting to handle more advanced clients too.
So far I'm okay with the progress, yeah.
Okay, okay, good to hear that. I think last when Ashish was working with you guys, he did mention about the server bit. I think that's only been triggered for JASP so far. Any luck with the other engineers?
Correct me if I'm wrong, but the surveys, the CFATs are only being triggered with Jack.
Sorry, can you repeat that?
Oh.
so far. I don't think it's been triggered for the other engineers.
Should be for all.
Also, what do you mean? What do you mean by triggered?
I mean, correct me if I'm wrong, Sarbjeet, because you've been joining those calls with Ashish as well. The surveys from the last call that I remember, Ashish did mention that he's only receiving the CSATs for Jasmine, not for the other engineers. Is that right?
Yes, that's true. So what happens when we are receiving the centralized reports, Reza, for all the engineers, for the end users, when they are reaching out to the end users for their CSAT response? So these responses were created by Jeremy.
Mmh.
Hi.
Ha.
But...
Okay, so Jeremy gonna prepare those reports for you, right?
Sure, so Keith, just to help you out with this thing, so we can reach out to Jeremy, specifying the dates of the engineer, and then Jeremy is going to add the engineer list in the reporting part.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Okay, cool, cool. So we'll reach out to Jeremy in that case for sure.
Yeah.
Sure.
And, and sir, so you're the CSATs are being triggered; is that the reporting piece is not there for these individuals? That OK, perfect. That makes more sense.
Yes, so.
Yeah, yeah, see, that is in place for everyone, but I think you need to reach to Jeremy to and ask for the report, because I don't have access to the bulk report. I can get that, I can get report one by one. It's time consuming. The best, the best guy is Jeremy.
Perfect.
****.
OK.
Got it. I'll reshare my screen.
I've noted that down as well. Connect with Jeremy after this.
All right, thanks for the feedback, Arkadi. We'll jump on to the numbers. We'll talk about the ITBD recommended KPIs. I think we've already walked you guys through this list of what the recommended KPIs are. I can skip this for now. Very quickly, the highlights. Q3 training roadmap approved, training confirmed through end of September, curriculum covers Microsoft 365, Azure Entra, Active Directory, Exchange, Intune, and SharePoint with Hands on Labs.
JASP positive performance recognition, Reza recognized JASP while identifying client security incident following the document escalation process and taking appropriate action before the security team was available. Ticket reassignment, something that was brought up on the last call, a process deviation involving ticket handoff was reviewed. The client treated it as a coaching opportunity. The team has been directed to use shared.
Helpdesk channels, not DMs, when transferring to urgent ticket ownership to ensure full visibility and accountability is there. Of course, a BOM handover is required here. Paxton shift timing, that piece is closed now, Arkadi. So from the decided date, you'll be working on the desired shift. So I'll change this point here.
S.
Thank you.
Right.
Very quickly, action tracker, awaiting 360 90 day plan. That's currently awaiting. Rest, everything else is completed. That's one only that's currently in progress. Operational alignment discussion that's currently ongoing. But I think that's it. Nothing else to discuss here. I'll jump on to the performance analysis real quick.
Earlier, I think Ashish used to showcase the numbers on each slide for each individual. I've kind of correlated it into one slide. Let me know if you want to make any changes to it, but we'll jump on to JASP performance first. 83% billable, 33.2 hours total, 22 tickets closed during this period.
As requested the last time, you wanted the segregation of the tickets that they work on based on the MACDs and service requests, incidents, and triages. That's what I've tried to do based on the note tickets, the list of tickets that they've shared with me. So for JASP incidents with 12%, that was 3 tickets in total, service requests 44%, MACDs 25%, and triage 18%.
number of calls that he picked out. Sorry, this is for the period I did not mention is between 15th to 21st. The number of calls that he picked during that period was 12. Recognized while identifying client security incident, that's something that we already talked about in the previous slide. We jump on to Jimmy. He has been 57% billable, 25.5 hours in total, and 12 tickets closed during this period.
The.
with incidents being 25%, service request 33%, Magdi's 25, and triage 17%. Total number of calls that he picked was 9. As compared to the other individuals, his billable hours are comparatively less. There have been more administrative hours, which we can discuss about in a bit. And then Paxton, 75%.
S.
available 30.2 hours in total and 19 tickets closed during this period. The incidents, number of incidents rather, the percentage of incidents that he worked on out of these 19 tickets were 26%, that is 5 tickets. Service requests 42%, that is 8 tickets. MACD's 21%, 4 tickets and triage 11%, 2 tickets. Number of calls he handled.
was 7. Good ticket hygiene and internal notes maintained, shift timings updated as per Arkadi's request. I'm going to skip for lunch, as you mentioned, Reza, but anything you'd like to bring up based on these numbers.
Based on these numbers, if we focus on Jasp, I see the work distribution that you mentioned here, which is good. You mentioned that three incidents he handled, 7 service requests, MAC these two. I just consider MAC this as a service request, totally fine, and three are just four.
Let's put aside the triage and calls from the list, because you know when you triage a ticket, you're not going to assign a ticket to yourself. It's A triage bar. And calls are not going to end it with tickets. So if you focus on incident and service request and MACD IC12 tickets,
Mhm.
Mm.
Handled by Jas on this week, but yeah, I see 22 closed ticket he handled during the week. To me, it means he worked on some ticket which was for last week and closed those ticket those one, if so.
Mhm.
And.
Mm.
Why we have no number, why we don't have those numbers in work distribution? Because it's already open ticket. We should have those numbers in the work distribution. If you mentioned these tickets are new ticket that assigned to them during the work weekday, I would say the numbers are good.
Okay.
Mhm.
But to me, the best way is having a column for new tickets that we assigned to a technician and another column is the total ticket that they have during the week. So we can compare those numbers and then those numbers would be accurate if we see 22 close tickets happen for.
Mm.
Sure.
Like.
Exactly.
Mhm.
You see the closed ticket is 20. 20 out of the new ticket assigned or the closed ticket and how many tickets assigned to those. And same for Paxton. And then we can see what exactly happened for the utilization, because Jimmy's utilization is low. 57.
Yeah.
Mm.
Yes.
Yeah.
is low, we should figure out why. Might be some administrative stuff, might be triage, but when I see the triage number, the triage number is 2, so it can't be triage. If, yeah, if we want to have some numbers that we can.
Mhm.
Mmh.
Yeah.
True.
have better understanding about those. We need more columns, I see.
Yeah, true, true. And the 22 closed, like you got that right. The number of closed tickets mentioned on top are not only new tickets or are carry forward tickets as well. So you're right, adding more columns and giving more clarity on numbers, what was carry forward from the previous month, rather previous week, and then what all came in that week and got closed.
OK.
Yeah.
that will give a better picture here. So that makes sense, Reza. Thanks for bringing that up. And yes, for Jimmy, the administrative hours, that's something that I noticed as well. And I was wondering, I was wanting to ask you as well, Reza, Arkadi, Torin, if there's any admin tasks handed over from you guys to him that he's working on that.
Um...
I mean, that's kind of, you know, dipping his utilization overall.
Nothing from my side, but one day, I think Friday, last Friday, he reached Jimmy and said, yeah, I need more tasks to do. And I have a list of off-the-shelf tasks. I had one big task which needs 2 technicians to handle it. I assigned it to Jimmy and one of our technicians in our side.
Mhm.
Mm.
say okay, it's a kind of coordination between you guys to handle this task. This task is not small task, so, but it's not admin task. They should put their time under the client side, bill the client about those, as it covers, I would say.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Half of our clients, so they need to create ticket, explain everything, and Arkadi is there in our chat, so I cannot consider it as a admin task. I'm not sure Arkadi touring if you guys assign some admin tasks to him.
Mhm.
Okay.
Mm.
No, at my direction, they went to Reza to get those off-the-shelf tasks, because those are not admin tasks. We want them to get away from those admin tasks as much as possible and to the more billable tasks to get their utilization up. So that's why they're reaching out, and we have an internal process to help them with that.
Mmh.
Yeah.
Mm.
Uh...
If we require help from your side to get that up, we will definitely do so. But for now, we're trying to address this internally first.
Mhm.
Right.
Yeah, we can check it too. We can check it this and this week and see what happens. Yeah, as you know, we have two different KPIs, kids for your information. One KPI is personal KPI for our technician. We're going to have a dashboard.
Mmh.
Kip.
Yeah.
Ch.
Mm.
for each technician, I think by the end of this month, or I would say middle of the next month, because we are already in the end of the month. But on that dashboard, you guys have access to as well. You can see the utilization, the number of the ticket that they handled.
Yeah.
S.
Bye.
the working hour that they entered, how many CSAT ticket they got. It's a full KPI personal dashboard, which is individual for everyone. And in another dashboard, we do have a team effort, which
Nice.
Mhm.
Mm.
is the conclusion of a couple of KPIs parameter from the individual to that dashboard, but as a team goal, like say, one of our team goal is the team utilization should be more than 75%.
Right.
Mm.
We're not going to assess and evaluate one by one of the technician. We see the whole effort that they put and check the utilization for the whole team and say, okay, regardless of your utilization, is 75 or 95 or 100.
Okay.
The team should have at least 75%. So it's one shared goal team. Another one is the phone call. Longest waiting time for the phone call should be less than two minutes. So
Yeah.
And.
Mm.
Might have Jazz Paxton, Jimmy, or who else had helped us and handled call less than 30 seconds, but the whole team number is like more than two minutes. It's a shared goal for the team. They should encourage each other to.
S.
Mm.
Okay.
Bad answer the phone calls to bad the level up the team KPI and other stuff that they had, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Arkadi.
Oh yeah, Reza reminded me, one of the...
Not issues, but one of the ideals that I have for ITBD technicians is to help the team more when it comes to phone calls. That is the number one way that they can help us is to be more proactive on answering phone calls.
Mmh.
Instead of waiting for me to ask, to take the initiative and to pick up those calls, the sooner the better, right? The longer the user is waiting on the phone, the worse their experience, obviously, right? The quicker the answer, the more impressed the client is, and the more likely they are to give them.
OK.
Bing them, yeah.
Mm.
Of course.
good CSAT rating as well, right? Because then they just quick pick up, quick help, or quick escalation, everybody's happy, and our stats are good as well, right? Their stats are good. So that is my ideal both for Ronan and for Paxton, for Jimmy, and for Jasp is to...
True.
OK, OK.
help out as much as possible on the phones. If they can make that their number one priority, that would be a huge help to me.
Absolutely, absolutely, and it's not a very big task, I mean, very big ask. It's very, very fair on your side. I'll make sure the message is cascaded to the team, Arkadi.
Exactly.
Thank you, thank you.
Right, perfect.
All right, post that, we'll see the numbers. Sorry, there you go. The billable utilization again, Jasp at 83%, Wunch 85, Jimmy 57%, Paxton 75%. That's, of course, the target line, as you can see, is 80%. Only 2 were able to touch that mark. We won't talk about, yes, Wunch was one of them.
I.
Glad, but then apart from that now, from next time on was, of course, we'll be showcasing Ronan's numbers here. And I've heard he's doing good when it comes to utilization. So that's a win for all of us together. If I jump on to the ticket closures, Jasper, 20, yeah, Reza, sorry, go ahead.
Yeah, yeah, in this slide that you shared, one of the things that I see is the numbers. 83% billable for JASP for 33.2 hours billable, which is perfect. If we go to Ranch, we see 85.
Mmh.
Mm.
Mhm.
for 32.8 hours. It's A mismatch in the calculation. How is that possible that the technician worked 33.2 hours B-level, but the utilization is 83, while another technician worked less with higher B-level utilization?
Hmm.
I think, I think you need to back to the formula might there is a mismatch in formula and that just this numbers.
If I recheck my...
Row number here.
Just give me a second, please.
I think it's for not for now, 'cause you know we have 3 minutes today of the meeting and we have to jump on another stuff, so we can move on.
Because the number of...
Yeah.
Mhm.
Ah, okay, but I'll take that as an action item for myself, because the overall hours that he had for the last week was around 38 hours, not 40. It should have been 40, and then based on that 38 hours, it picked up 85% for that. But I'll check on that piece and let you know what happened here for sure, Reza, over a chat. All right, very quickly, a few seconds left, the numbers of...
Kip.
I see.
tickets that they closed. This is something we already saw on the first slide, but yeah, just focusing on the ticket closures, 22 for Jazz, 1 for 20, Paxton 19 and Jimmy 12. This is not just the new tickets, these are the tickets that were carried forward from the previous week as well, Reza. So I'll skip this. The slides will be shared with you guys for reviewing.
Yeah.
in case you have any questions apart from the ones that we just talked about, because I'll be getting back to you with the answers. If there's anything that you like to add or raise, just do let me know or the email or chat, whatever suits you guys.
Yeah, sure. I want one of the parameter I think it would be helpful is having the same day resolution ticket if you if you can have those numbers would be perfect. If it's not possible and or it's hard for you to grab those information from the system, we will add it to
Yeah. Absolutely. Absolutely.
Mm.
But their KPI, their individual KPI, then you have access to no rush on that, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that'll be very helpful. That'll be very helpful because now I'll have to unfortunately go into these ticket and see.
I think once we have that dashboard available, no need for you guys to go ahead and grab all those things and put things together. I know it's hard. Then we can speak on what we really have in our site. And we have it all, we are all on the same page about the numbers.
Yeah.
Awesome.
then we can focus on those numbers only.
Yeah.
Perfect. Sounds good. Sounds like a plan. Thank you. Thank you, Reza.
Kip.
Yep, Kip.
One very quick thing. So we're very sad that Vanj didn't work out. I just want to say that he is quite good technically on technical level. Just in his future training, if you want to emphasize something to help him improve, is to help logical thinking.
Mhm.
Paying attention to details, thinking before jumping into the situation. It's like, if you know, check if the if the pool is empty before you jump in, right? Check if there is water in the pool before you jump in, right? So, just helping develop those skills, which are...
Soft skills, not necessarily technical skills, right?
That's a very good feedback Arkadi. And like I said, we're going to have an oriented call with Jessel regarding lunch. So this is something that I'll definitely share with him. And we'll of course share with lunch as well. That's very helpful.
Sounds good. Sounds good.
Thank you, Arkadi.
Thank you, Arkadi. Thank you. I think we're good then. If anything pops up, I'm just one chat away. Thank you so much, gentlemen, for joining. One last question before you guys jump off. We, it's Monday. We again have a call on Wednesday. Do you think it's fair to skip the Wednesday's call and then connect next week again? Is that fine?
Kip.
Wednesday, the Canadian holiday. It's a holiday.
Wednesday is is the off, so, so, so it's already it's already escaped, don't worry about that.
Holiday for us on Wednesday anyway. Oh yeah, any which way. Okay, cool. So any which way we're connecting next week.
Yeah, it's frozen.
Kip.
Yes.
Yeah.
Cool, then we'll connect next week then.
I...
Yeah, I think, no, no, yeah, for next week, yeah, we do, but I think on Thursday we would have a call, orientation call, right?
Yeah, yes, correct. So I'll check with Jessel for the timings and connect with you, Reza.
Okay.
Sure, sure, and just, just for recap, after our calls, Sarbjeet, if you have time to work with Arkadi on that, the preliminary steps that we need to handle, it would be perfect. Thank you.
Sounds good.
Mhm.
For sure.
For sure, let me get the list of IP shared with you, Arkadi, and then I'll ring you separately so that we can go through the details. I'll loop Ketan as well.
Right.
K.
Sounds good. Thank you.
Thank you, thank you guys, and I apologize for my my my camera. I don't know, I don't know what happened to my camera. It's keeping this kind of even kind of, I don't know what happened. It should open a ticket. OK, thank you guys.
Yeah.
Thanks, Das.
Thank you.
No problem at all.
See.
Yeah.
Mm.
That's perfectly fine.
Escalate, there is a escalate, yeah, yeah, send it to escalations.
It's just Monday. Thank you, everyone. Bye, bye.
Yeah.
Thanks, Keith. Bye, everyone.
Thank you, everyone. Have a great day.
Have a good rest of the day. Bye.